tiempo para la economía aquí en France
24 para ello ya Contamos con nuestro
compañero Jorge Hurtado aquí en el
estudio Jorge vamos a hablar de una de
las noticias de la semana aquí en
Latinoamérica es Perú porque ya los
paros y las protestas están afectando a
su economía y es que por años en la
economía peruana se mantuvo estable
frente a estas crisis y logró un
crecimiento sostenido que solamente la
pandemia del Coby 19 pudo pausar pero la
violencia callejera que desató la
destitución del presidente Pedro
Castillo ahora es uno de los mayores
desafíos para lo que muchos expertos
llaman el milagro peruano este milagro
se debe a los niveles de reserva sólidos
niveles de deuda bajos y también una
amplia apertura comercial que incentivó
el comercio nacional así como una
constitución que facilita y protege la
inversión privada sin dejar de mencionar
por supuesto la independencia del Banco
Central que ayudó a este crecimiento
económico de Perú pero ahora desde el
turismo hasta las exportaciones todos
los sectores económicos se ven afectados
por estas protestas que exigen el cierre
del Congreso y también la salida de la
presidenta
nuestra compañera Gabriel colchón nos da
más contexto de esta crisis en el
siguiente reporte
las protestas no cesan en Perú en 10 de
sus 25 regiones varias carreteras
continúan bloqueadas el pedido de los
manifestantes es el mismo la dimisión de
la presidenta Gina boluarte el
aeropuerto de cusco que permite Acceder
al Machu Picchu fue cerrado por
prevención en la capital Lima miles de
personas se reunieron de forma pacífica
a la llamada de sindicatos y partidos de
izquierda
[Música]
denuncian las muertes en las protestas
que llegan casi al medio centenar
[Música]
señora son tantas muertes por Dios paren
con toda esa masacre no es justo Yo sé
que la gente me está saliendo a
protestar es gente que está indignada
como yo y no nos está interrumpiendo que
no somos terrucos entre tú el ministro
de trabajo Eduardo García virimiza
presentó su dimisión en una carta a la
presidenta en la cual instó el gobierno
a pedir disculpas y organizar elecciones
anticipadas se requiere que se pida
disculpas a la población y que se
reconozca que se han cometido errores y
que deben ser corregidos para que esto
no se repita la situación amerita un
cambio de rostros en la dirección del
país y un adelanto de elecciones que no
puede ya esperar hasta abril de 2024
Pero vive una intensa ola de
manifestaciones así como el peor brote
de violencia en décadas consecuencia de
la destitución del presidente Pedro
Castillo a principio de diciembre tras
sus intentos por disolver el congreso
una delegación Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos al país suramericano
para verificar la situación de los
Derechos Humanos
Jorge en concreto cómo se está
comportando la economía ante esta crisis
en Perú bueno en 2022 esa economía cerró
con un crecimiento del dos coma nueve
por ciento pese a las denuncias de
corrupción y también los pedidos de
destitución del entonces presidente
Castillo ahora el instituto de economía
y desarrollo empresarial de la cámara de
comercio de Lima estima que la economía
peruana registraría una desaceleración
en 2023 con un crecimiento en torno al
dos coma cuatro por ciento ese dato
incluye a la minería uno de los sectores
más afectados por estas protestas que
logrará un alza estimada del 5,7% por el
ingreso de nuevas unidades cupríferas el
sector de servicios que aporta la mitad
del producto interno bruto caerá al 3,1%
según el organismo y su recuperación
estadís en condicionada a la estabilidad
social los economistas estiman que la
paralización productiva cuesta unos 50 o
60 millones de dólares diarios En los
días más fuertes de las protestas
del sector hotelero se calcula que el
80% de las reservas de la ciudad de
cusco fueron canceladas cientos de
turistas quedaron varados y fueron
evacuados en Machu Picchu el gremio
turístico Calcula pérdidas en torno a
los 260 millones de dólares en las
últimas dos semanas Mientras tanto la
agencia es anti global rating bajó la
calificación de deuda de moneda
extranjera a largo plazo del Perú a
negativa esto por un mayor estancamiento
político pues Jorge como siempre Muchas
gracias por este repaso económico
seguimos
[Música]